and we see these cars and like you said
there's such variation such wild
imagination and it feels like maybe
modern cars aren't quite as free what
changed well what changed was that in
those days of the 50s and 60s if you had
an idea you could build a car at home
the garage and then you could just start
selling it because there was no rules
and regulations not much subleased and
today of course we have so many rules
that you've got to go through approvals
you've got to go through crash testing
and it cost millions and millions and
it's very hard for people to understand
why do you need to raise half a billion
dollars to make a car these days well it
really has to do with all these rules
and regulations emission testing etc so
that has changed a lot however that said
I do believe the reason we come back
here is because we are trying to find
out how do we bring this emotion back
into cars because we are in a state
right now where a lot of young people
are not so excited about cars because
they kind of become a little boring and
the cool thing now is all our smart
device is not rid of the car that's a
really good point you have of course
you're famous for the fisker karma car
talk to me a little bit about how
electric power trains might affect
design aesthetics both from a practical
sense and also from just a pure
aesthetic sense so one of the things I'm
doing research on right now is really to
look into taking the electric powertrain
and actually look at how can we get some
of these beautiful shapes back and one
of the interesting things about electric
power trains is that we're actually
freeing up space because we're taking
which senses the heart of the car which
is the battery and putting underneath
the floor or somewhere not in front of
the rear so what happens is today with
cars you have so much space in the front
or is taking up by I have the engine of
the gas tank and then a trouble that a
lot of electronic boxes so I think with
the reduction of electronics boxes
specifically and the complexity and then
the electric powertrain we're gonna be
able to reap reports in the cars and
actually I think we're gonna be able to
bring some of that beauty back so that
sort of some of the research I'm doing
right now to kind of see how can we
bring this emotion and excitement back
to power
and I think the electric powertrain
might allow us that that's interesting
that's really exciting I mean that makes
it seem like you're optimistic about the
future of design potentially I'm very
optimistic I think we've gone through
some of the last 20 years where it was
pretty gloom and everybody sort of
became you know common alized everybody
did the same thing and today to be
honest it's very hard to see the
difference between you know
top-of-the-line sedan from many
different companies if you're not an
expert and if it's all the silver I
think at least what I'm working on I
believe that we can come back and repr
Porsche in the car with electric power
trains but I also think it has something
to do quite frankly with a stablish car
industry the established car industry
has now become so big is these giant
conglomerates and they're very afraid of
jumping out of the box and what you're
seeing now is some startups and I think
the new car companies you're gonna see
they're gonna take these risk they're
gonna try and they have to try to lower
back the customers with amazing
beautiful vehicle